more than 150 years after the Civil War
there's a new push across the south to
take down Confederate monuments in at
least five states critics say the
statutes celebrate slavery and recession
and secession defenders argue the
memorials on a southern heritage
officials in Austin Texas and Louisville
Kentucky have already voted to remove
statutes New Orleans is about to do the
same Jan Crawford is in Charlottesville
Virginia with the fight over a monument
to a famous Confederate General Jan good
morning good morning Charlie so this
statue of Robert Ely was put up nearly a
hundred years ago but here as in other
cities across the south these
Confederate symbols now are at the
center of a bitter debate about how we
define our past as we move forward as a
nation their relics of a painful past
memorials to a war generals whose names
are etched in history
Stonewall Jackson Robert Ely but now
there are new battle grounds from
Charlottesville to New Orleans
Confederate monuments have been
vandalized and some cities have voted to
remove them all part of a public debate
over whether these statues memorialize
racism symbolism matters when you say
symbolism matters that's the symbol of
what it's a symbol in my personal
opinion white supremacy and this
assemble that we cannot have in the
middle of our city Charlottesville City
Councilman West Bellamy has led the
fight to move the town statue of Robert
Ely but opponents led by attorney
Charles Weber argue the statue
symbolizes something else these are war
memorials that exist for one purpose to
honor the men who fought it's not it's
not to promote a cause of the war is not
the glorify war is to honor the men who
fought Weber points to a Virginia law
similar to others across the south that
block cities and towns from removing war
memorials this statute could never be
moved it has to stay here yes forever
yes even though many people find this
terribly offensive
offensive it is the is a way to stop a
conversation about the meaning of the
statute alright it's not a way to start
the conversation University of South
Carolina professor Thomas Brown studies
Confederate symbols there are hundreds
of these across the landscape of the
South the controversies over removal of
monuments are partly over
well what who is going to decide exactly
what that public space is going to
endorse for years these fights focused
on the Confederate flag which largely
has disappeared from public spaces a
reflection of changing attitudes
position to change runs deep and can
turn personal up and so I should be
taken behind the watershed in
Charlottesville supporters of the statue
unearthed crude tweets written by
Bellamy as a younger man and he also was
targeted with death threats the Bellamy
feels his fight is justified we've seen
there's still a lot of issues in regards
to race here in this community and the
only way for us to move forward is to
deal with them head-on
now while this legal fight continues
city officials here in Charlottesville
will review a plan next week with
recommendations on where to put this
twenty eight foot statue if it's ever
allowed to be moved a problem other
cities across the south are likely to
have to face Nora
Jim thank you it's an important story
it's going to spark a lot of debate on
the flag from the flag to statutes yes
changing history